these are all 10 users of the one for
all Quirk the Legendary Power passed on
throughout the generation in order to
stop the ultimate villain known as all
for one and the very first user was none
other than the villain's younger brother
yoichi shigaraki yoichi was presumed to
be quirkless and could only watches his
brother all for one committed atrocities
around the world when his brother
forcibly implanted a power stockpiling
Quirk within him it was discovered that
he really did have a quirk one with no
other power than it could be transferred
to others these two quirks then merged
with ruichi and ultimately one for all
was created due to his sickly State he
was unable to make good use of his
Newfound power instead he decided to
pass it on to other people in hopes that
his new court would get stronger over
time and that eventually someone strong
enough would inherit it and stop his
older brother once and for all yuichi
had a strong sense of justice and was
willing to stand against his brother
despite his weak body and his brother
amassing a large collection of powerful
quirks and loyal followers several
decades later when all for one in tamura
tried to steal one for all from Deku
yoichi resisted them in the Vestige
world even tomoda was stunned by
yuichi's willpower as Quirk types tend
to run in families it's likely that
yoichi's transference Quirk always had
the ability to absorb the quirks that
came into contact with much like how his
brother's court could also take in
multiple quirks this is most likely what
allowed his Quirk to absorb and combine
with the power stockpiling Quirk and
create one for all although yuichi
couldn't do anything against his brother
the second user was actually the leader
of the resistance movement that tried to
stop all for one before we continue I'd
like to ask you guys to subscribe to the
channel I literally paid an artist to
make this drag of Deku holding a
subscribe button so it would really mean
a lot if you could subscribe thanks
anyway the second user has a large scar
across the front of his face when she
received during his final battle against
all for one and wears a combat jacket
with a large black collar he's also
equipped with a pair of gauntlets on his
arms which he uses to attack using
projectiles powered up by his meta
ability gear shift aside from leaving a
resistance movement against all for one
he also did everything he could to fight
back including taking the lives of
anyone who stood in his way for example
he initially had plans to to kill yuichi
due to his ties to all for one but after
learning that yuichi actually opposed
his brother's actions he changed his
mind and chose to save him instead this
action inadvertently is what allowed one
for all to grow and be passed on at
first he refused to accept Deku as a
successor to The Quirk due to his
optimistic and childish desires but was
eventually convinced by yuichi and by
seeing some of deku's recent
achievements after daku tried to use his
meta ability for the first time he
reminded the young hero that using this
ability should be a last resort since
the power can be devastating if not used
carefully he then provided deku's
support when he activated gear shift and
warned him he'll only be able to use it
for five minutes his proficiency with
one for all is unknown however he
probably wasn't a big threat to All For
One considering that the villain
compared his gear shift ability to
peashooter the third one for all user
was also a part of the same resistance
movement fighting against all for one he
was also there alongside the second gear
user during the assassination attempt on
yuichi he was a man with hair tied in a
spiky ponytail with a black bandana
covering his forehead and wore a combat
jacket with a pair of small Escape tubes
coming out of his shoulders just like
the second user he also refused to
accept Deku as a successor to the port
before coming around to it thanks to
yuichi his proficiency with one for all
is unknown but he most likely used it in
conjunction with his given Quirk fajin
this Quirk allowed him to build up
kinetic energy by repeating regular
motions and store it for later use when
the user chooses to release the energy
it gain an explosive burst of speed and
power fudging is actually named after
the Chinese martial art technique with
the same name number four hikage
shinomori unlike the other users higage
chose not to confront all for one aware
of the enormous power gap between them
and instead spent his time in seclusion
training himself in strengthening one
for all for his successor during the
final years of his life his body started
to break down causing scars ikage's
original Quirk is called danger sense
and it allowed him to sense incoming
threats in the surrounding area giving
him ample opportunity to react to them
according to Deku once a threat is
detected a stabbing sensation is sent to
the user's head in all mate's notes
about the previous one for all users he
scribbled out hika case cause of death
it was revealed that all might scribbled
out the cause of death due to suspicions
he had about one for all side effects
and thanks to this the users learned the
truth about the power anyone who wields
one for all and already possesses a
quirk will have their life span
shortened due to the burden of powers on
the body therefore only ones who are
quarkless can wield one for all and use
its full potential hikake was one of the
users who wielded this power for the
longest the full 18 years shortly before
dying hikage passed one for all onto the
next user number five daguro banjo
daiguro was formerly known as the Pro
Hero Lariat describing as being super
funky his proficiency with one for all
is unknown though we likely used it in
conjunction with his given Quirk black
whip which allowed him to create
tendrils of black energy from his arms
veguro was a large muscular man of white
build usually wearing dark weathered
clothes golden stylish goggles and a
bandolier although very little is known
about this user at some point all for
one attempted to steal one for all from
him twice but failed this implies that
he had incredible willpower at some
point daiguro transferred one for all to
the next user after he was injured and
trapped under a pile of rubble he was
killed by All For One shortly after
transferring it there were five more
incredibly interesting characters to
cover and the next one is n Ben was a
former pro hero and the sixth user of
the one for all Quirk little is known
about Anne's proficiency with this work
other than he was not capable of
bringing down all for one same with
daiguro all for one also attempted to
steal the Quirk from n but failed
besides one for all and also had his own
Quirk called Smoke screen which is
actually a reference to his name since n
in Japanese means smoke this perk
allowed him to create clouds of smoke
which could obscure Vision at some point
is the sixth user he met in nanashimura
and after being fatally wounded in a
battle with all for one and gave Nana
some of his hair so she could become the
next one for all user number seven
narashimura Nana was the seventh user of
the one for all Quirk the former mentor
of all might and the grandmother of
tenko shimura she was a very
compassionate and Noble individual
regarded as a truly great and
exceptional hero it's not really known
how strong she was but same as previous
uses she wasn't strong enough to bring
down all for one none gave one
throughout the toshinori sometime prior
to her battle with all for one which
resulted in her death Nana also had
another Quirk called float which granted
her the ability to suspend herself in
midair the interesting fact about her is
that the word NADA means seven in
Japanese which is a reference to her
being the seventh one for all user only
three more characters are left and these
are some of the most powerful one for
all users in the entire series number 8.
has wielded one for all longer than any
other user for a total of 40 years while
almost all other users were either
killed by all for one or died of old age
the reason toshinari was able to hold
this Quirk for so long is because he was
born quirkless meaning he could bear the
burden of one for all much easier than
people who already had their Quirk
doshinluri would go on to become the
hero all might and throughout his career
he was regarded as the most powerful
hero of all time and remained undefeated
with the goal of being a pillar of
society and the symbol of peace he put
one for all to Great use defeating all
sorts of criminals rescuing countless
people from danger and turning himself
into a legend most notably he was the
first holder to to battle all for one
and win though he suffered severe and
untreatable damage that significantly
weakened him due to these injuries all
my transpiratory system and stomach were
left in very poor shape and from then on
he could only utilize his Quirk for
three hours a day anymore and it would
place too much strain on his body it was
for this reason he opted to become a
teacher at UA high school so that he
could find a successor to pass one for
all onto this was a perfect plan as he
would also have an explanation to the
public as to why he wasn't doing hero
work as often during his second battle
with all for one all might depleted a
majority of his remaining power from his
body in order to defeat the villain
essentially leaving him cordless once
again although he can still transform
for an instant he cannot maintain his
muscular form anymore as it causes great
strain on his body reverting back very
quickly having retired completely from
heroic activity as a result all might
now dedicates himself solely to
assisting Deku in mastering the power of
one for all so he may become a great
hero of his own number nine izukumi
Doria all might initially didn't plan on
passing his court to Deku but after
seeing his bravery and determination he
agreed to train him and chose him as his
successor initially Deku had very little
control over the Quirk and could only
use one for all at 100 power and only in
short bursts grievously injuring his
body each time while this allowed him to
unleash incredible displays of strength
it came at potentially lifelong physical
costs resulting in him currently having
a visibly scarred right hand and arm
this is because the training Deku did
prior to receiving The Quirk was only
the bare minimum needed for using one
for all without his limbs being blown
off completely later Dicky found a way
to minimize the damage to himself by
focusing one for all's power on just his
fingers while he still ended up breaking
his fingers he was able to strike
powerful blows and generate strong air
currents Deku eventually realized that
he was using one for all Sully in the
limbs and to correct this he developed
one for all full Cal this ability takes
advantage of the five percent the decade
can safely work with to increase his
overall strength and Agility by letting
this small amount permeate his entire
body using volcal Deku can easily scale
the side of buildings jump large
killings between structures and quickly
navigate through cluttered areas Deku
could react to the speed of Gran Torino
and even hold his own against stain in
his first real fight even so if Deku
does not remain aware and in control
while using his Quirk he might go over
his five percent limit and injure
himself during the fifth round of the
joint training session between classes
1A and 1B Dark Energy tendrils began to
fire from deku's arm that heavily
damaged his surroundings and pulled him
along against his will uraraka and
hitoshi were able to stop the Rampage by
brainwashing Deku and sending him into
his subconscious there he met Vigoro the
fifth user of one for all baiguro
explains that The Quirk factors of the
previous holders had merged with the
core of one for all and increased in
strength proportionally he also tells
Deku that there's five other courts that
he'll manifest in the future and that
the one he's currently manifested is his
own Quirk when he was alive a black whip
he later managed to awaken all of those
quirks in his future battles that means
float dangerous sense smokescreen paging
and gear shift two months later by the
time of the Paranormal Liberation word
deku's proficiency with one for all has
increased to allow him to momentarily
use 45 without breaking his body after
unlocking gear shift and combining it
with flashing through the ultimate move
overdrive deck he was capable of taking
that 100 of power and turning it into
what is described as a hundred and
twenty percent although Deku is the
current one for all users there's one
more character who briefly had the power
of this Quirk and it's none other than
bakugo in a desperate attempt to stop
nine Deku decided to transfer the Quirk
to bakugo by swapping blood through the
open wounds on their hands allowing both
of them to utilize the immense power
granted by one for all despite the
period of chance for him possession
being extremely brief bakugo
demonstrated great proficiency with the
Quirk he continues to use one for all
full Cal 100 without any prior
instruction and his body could handle
the sheer power of The Quirk without
being blown apart when bakugou used one
for all to enhance his given Quirk
explosion it became so powerful that
even standard blast could create
enormous craters in addition the
temperature of the explosions was also
greatly increased to the point where it
could melt through solid rock in a
similar manner to Lava at the end of his
and deku's fight against nine bakugou
lost once all and the court remained in
deku's body all might initially
suspected that the cork stayed with Deku
because bakugou lost Consciousness prior
to the transfer's completion but later
theorized that one for all kept itself
inside of Deku due to his willingness to
protect others even if it meant losing
the power this may mean that the
transfer only lets bakugou borrow some
of the one for all power without
actually possessing The Quirk